hey so i have something interesting for
you guys right now because
it is yet more trump flunky gaslighting
on corporate media but it's also a
super important uh kind of critical
thinking and epistemology
concept and it goes to the question of
mayo brained mark meadows didn't think
he was going to be instructive but
how do we know things we do observation
we sometimes
generalize we look to authorities we
apply research methods the scientific
method
it's a very big conversation but when
we're dealing with empirical questions
that you're not testing in a sort of
double-blind uh
format we need to apply some other
concepts which we are going to discuss
shortly and this leads us
to donald trump's chief of staff mark
meadows who went on cnn
and talked about the supposed voter
fraud of vote by mail that trump is
going to be
pushing to suppress vote by mail this
election and jake tapper from cnn points
out
there's no evidence of widespread voter
fraud when people vote by mail
and mark meadows says well there's no
evidence
that there isn't widespread voter fraud
take a look at this sending ballots out
just
just based on a voter roll registration
anytime you move you'll change your
driver's license
but you don't call up and say no out of
the way voter fraud though
but there's no evidence of widespread
voters there's no
there's no evidence that there's not
either that's the definition of fraud
jake when we look at that what we have
seen
are a number of about male 1 so this is
really instructive like not not only
does mark meadows skull
seem to be filled with mayonnaise here
or vegan a's if that's your your
preference
this leads us to occam's razor occam's
razor is a concept which
we often interpret or simplify as
if you have competing explanations for
something
we should prefer the simpler explanation
in the sense that it requires the fewest
assumptions
and fewest secondary explanations of
either unknown or
invisible phenomena so i'll give you
some examples if i say
that car seems to be running i hear it
running and the tachometer says a
thousand rpm
i am i believe the car has gasoline in
it
assuming it's not an electric car right
you could come out and say you don't
know that david
the car could be out of gas but you're
hearing a
speaker pumping out noise that sounds
like an engine that's running
and the tachometer might have been
manipulated to show a thousand even when
the car isn't really on
okay i mean i guess that's possible but
it's implausible and the first
explanation which is
when you see a car you hear the noise of
the car running
and the tachometer shows a thousand the
car probably has
gas it requires fewer assumptions and
the person suggesting the wacky
hypothesis should have to provide
evidence that they are right
you could say david you don't have proof
that my theory is false but intuitively
we know that
that's the person that should be proving
to us that we should consider
their hypothesis another example if i
say
look it's an empty room you could say
there could be an invisible tiger in
here and i'd say well if there was an
invisible tiger in here we would still
hear the tiger
the tiger might smell we might see the
tiger moving around dust as it walks
around
and you could say no no the tiger is
invisible but it's also
odorless and weightless and silent it
doesn't make any noise
and you don't have proof that that's not
going on i think you get the idea these
are indefeasible arguments you can't
defeat them
because they will always say well you
haven't proved otherwise definitively
jake tapper of course should have said
you're asserting some
something for which there is no evidence
so the onus
is on you to prove it simply saying it
hasn't been proven that there isn't
voter fraud is not
actually sufficient now it gets even
crazier during this interview here mark
meadows claims
that despite numerous reports no voting
machines have been taken offline but if
they were taken offline it's definitely
barack obama's fault
are you saying that sorting machines
have not been taken offline and removed
are you asserting that that did not
happen i i'm saying that
shorting machines between now and the
election will not be taken offline
listen i i had postal under my the ones
that have been taken offline
no no no but listen here's what i'm
saying is
when you look at it the normal process
of doing all of this jake
uh i had the postal system under i had
the only bipartisan bill to actually
deal with the 146 billion dollar loss
that the postal service has been uh
we'll see over the next 10 years
and so when you're looking at this these
postal machines and the
the drawdown that was a 2006 bill that
has been implemented
that i don't necessarily agree with but
that's not this postmaster general that
that
that did that that was the previous
postmaster general
under obama so if you're struggling to
understand that you aren't alone do not
adjust your brain it's actually
incoherent
voting machines haven't been taken
offline but there was a bill under obama
to do it
but it hasn't happened this time but it
did happen but not now
so if it's because of that bill that you
see it then blame obama
what then jake tapper provides evidence
that actually
voting machines are being taken offline
and mark meadows says oh
it's all normal and nothing to be
alarmed about but remember he said
minutes earlier
that it wasn't happening at all in terms
of the fact check that you asked me to
look into
yeah one of my great producers did in
terms of the machines
chris bentley president of the national
postal mail handlers union local 297
which covers kansas
and part of missouri two good trump
states told cnn
that postal management has already taken
out four machines in kansas city
two machines in springfield missouri and
one machine in wichita kansas
that is earlier this year under this new
postmaster general
no no no with all due respect and and if
we look at it i can talk
to kansas i can talk to tucson arizona
you're talking to someone who knows is
when we take out those processing
they're part of a processing center that
come comes in
and as we start to move those out if
they were not part
of an already scheduled reallocation
it's not happening it's not a new
initiative by this postmaster general
and when we look at this
it's all about efficiency but you have a
normal system of changing it out
and so with with all due respect of your
fact checker
i'll be glad to come in we can spend an
hour talking about this we'll bore
people to death but i can tell you this
the post office has been losing money
for over 10 years okay so
the full explanation is this isn't
happening
if it is it's barack obama's fault not
the current postmaster general
but since it is happening it's actually
not happening now oh well no but it is
but it was the previous postmaster
general whose influence is actually
what's responsible here
and anyway we should treat the post
office like a business instead of the
public service that it is
this is trump's chief of staff this is
not some random congressman
anymore he was some random congressman
now this is donald trump's chief of
staff
we're in real trouble heading into this
election
one of our sponsors today is helix sleep
and it's a sponsor
i'm thrilled about because i sleep on a
helix mattress at home
and it's just the perfect mattress one
of the best things about helix is
you don't have to guess which mattress
do i need which one will be good for me
you take their famous sleep quiz on
their website you tell them your body
type
your sleeping position your back pain
issues you might have
and they will pair you with a mattress
that will be perfect for you
i took the sleep quiz the mattress they
suggested was exactly what i needed i
often get too hot at night
the mattress keeps me cool it's not too
soft it's not too firm the texture is
right
and i've just been getting way better
sleep you only buy a mattress
every decade or so don't get stuck with
something that's not perfect
for you and all helix mattresses come
with a 10-year warranty
and they'll even come to your house and
pick it up within a hundred days
if you don't love it but i think you
will all of my viewers will get up to
200
off your order and you'll get two super
premium pillows
for free when you go to the link right
underneath this video